that's my point you guys are getting
ungrateful you guys have lost sight of
the fact that our bodies were perfectly
designed to have sex with you
anatomically whatever you believe in say
it's evolution or god say you believe in
god god perfectly designed the female
body to have sex with you right vagina
here
perfect placement
boobs here if you want a little
perfect
the head moves back and forth in case
you don't want to look at her face
god thought of everything
and then god was putting the female body
together and i was like ugh
there's this other hole
it's a terrible hole
horrible things come out of it it's
awful
we can't put it in the front
or else men would never have sex with
women
god's like you know what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna hide it
i'm gonna put it in the back
in like
a ravine
i'm gonna put big pieces of fat on
either side of it
we'll never even know it's there she can
walk away naked he'll never see it it's
genius
genius
the female body is complete
cut to god looking down now a guy's like
god's like oh my god
how did they even find it
i hid that thing pretty well
they're animals
no
no no
no not squirting nope
we're starting a movement here tonight
hashtag no squirting get it going
no you know why it's you guys are
pushing it now you're ungrateful you're
spoiled and you're pushing it like do
our bodies not do enough amazing things
enough miraculous things we can make a
life we can get pregnant we can
breastfeed our babies we can give you
orgasms now you want us to put out fires
it's too much
that's too much
and i'm a pretty slutty person the fact
that there's something i won't do that's
bad that is off the grid
okay i'll do anything i will literally
do anything because i'm fun i am fun
okay i'll do anything what do you want
spank me great go for it i will try not
to laugh but go for it
choking that's the new thing everyone's
got to get choked now choke me great
choke me i'll even throw in a little
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm fun
i'm fun
but you're pushing it now okay i'm not
squirting
with time for that okay i'm not gonna
clean up squirts no
i have a job i don't have time for that
you gotta go to home depot
gotta get a tarp
you gotta put the tarp down my bedroom
looks like dexter's garage
not living that way
was sex not awkward enough before
squirting
do you remember the awkward talk before
sex used to be like hey do you have a
condom
now it's like hey do you have a sham wow
[Applause]
shit's about to get crazy
you don't want me to squirt you do not
want me to squirt cause if i could
squirt i would use it for evil all the
time
anytime i was in my boyfriend's car i'd
be like you sure you want to text that
girl back
i didn't think so
i'm worried i'm worried for the next
generation of boys because now guys in
their teenage kids they watch porn now
before they ever actually see a naked
woman before they ever actually have sex
they're watching porn and they think
that's gonna happen they think that
women are just these
human bellagio fountains
just squirting constantly
they think they're gonna walk into that
remember our generation of boys they
would show up to lose their virginity
with like a rose
now kids show up to lose their virginity
just a snorkel an umbrella just flippers